[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yann sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
natacha polony la directrice de la
rédaction de l'hebdomadaire marianne qui
publie un livre titre provocant sommes
nous encore en démocratie aux édition de
l'observatoire
un titre qui doit faire frissonner
natacha les médias bon chic bon genre on
va dire mais mais j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ne vous combattent pas vraiment
j'ai l'impression qu'au fond ils vous
adore je pense que il
disons qu'ils aiment bien frissonner et
tremblay c'est à dire que je suis le la
forme la plus acceptable de ceux qui ne
rentrent pas dans leurs critères dire
que quand on le lit je pense qu'on peut
à aucun moment m'accuser d'avoir une
quelconque proximité avec une forme de
de fascisme d'autoritarisme on peut
difficilement me classer dans les
extrêmes
donc du coup il est difficile de me
diaboliser
je pense que dans la mesure où mes
arguments sont des arguments
disons qu'ils les prennent à leurs
propres à leur propre jeu c'est à dire
que moi que je le redis c'est je suis
plus démocrate que vous regardez ce que
de ce qu'est devenue la démocratie le
système que vous avez mis en place n'est
pas démocratique
mais ça veut pas dire que moi j'estime
qu'il faudrait remplacer ce système par
une dictature par l'autorité simplement
je j'estime qu'il y a un travail
absolument énorme avant de de
véritablement remettre en place une
démocratie digne de ce nom
donc c'est un petit peu compliqué moi de
me wade de mettre à l'écart ou de me
diaboliser ça marche pas ouais vous êtes
la bonne marâtre on va dire celle qui
vient qui tape tape sur les doigts mais
on peut pas lui en vouloir elle est
sévère mais juste il se trouve qu'en
plus au moment même où sort ce livre il
ya cette étude
2 y est que le mist qui viennent de
paraître et les économistes qui est
quand même un très très grand journal
the economist classe la france parmi les
démocraties défaillante
on est à la 24e place on va le voir là
c'est celle est bon élève et puis là
arrivent
la france est derrière la corée du sud 1
juste avant les états unis mais ce bond
se tait les états unis donald trump
c'est pas terrible mais c'est au moment
c'est le comportement de la france
autant de démocratie face à la crise
sanitaire
c'est donc un moment très particulier
vous avez dû le voile avoir cette étude
oui bien sûr alors le problème de cette
étude c'est que si vous regardez bien
votre tableau la france est au dessus
des 8 c'est-à-dire classé dans les
vraies démocraties bien uniquement en
parce qu'avant on était encore plus bas
qu'aujourd'hui donc ça veut dire que les
critères qui sont utilisés doivent quand
même attiré notre attention c'est moi je
trouve ça formidable ce genre de
classement mais si vous regardez dans
les très bons élèves vous avez l'irlande
les pays bas le luxembourg c'est à dire
des paradis fiscaux qui sont en train de
détruire l'europe de l'intérieur mais ça
ça pose aucun problème
donc je pense que il faut se méfier le
diagnostic qui consiste à dire le court
aux navires us a été l'occasion d'une
réduction des libertés individuelles et
d'une forme d'autoritarisme qui est
extrêmement problématique
ça c'est évident en revanche utiliser ce
classement pour ça cesse
il vaut mieux être extrêmement méfiant
parce qu'en fait c'est un classement qui
est pétri d'une conception très
particulière de la démocratie qui est la
conception anglo-saxonne c'est à dire
que là en gros ce sont les démocraties
libérales qui sont bien classés si on
regarde en fait pour que ce classement a
été fait soit fait il ya une soixantaine
de critères et parmi les critères il ya
par exemple la liberté religieuse c'est
à dire que la laïcité à la française ça
nous fait perdre des points
comprenez c'est pas c'est ça fait pas
très démocratie libérale donc je pense
que le diagnostic qui consiste à dire
l'année 2020 a été une année de
régression de la démocratie oui c'est
une évidence sur la tribu
est ce que pour autant il faut
considérer que ce classement de the
economist c'est le juge de paix je ne
pense pas la liberté religieuse se
désole dans la laïcité à la française
elle est très proche de la ici de la
liberté religieuse dans les pays anglo
saxon dans les pays anglo saxons c'est
depuis qu'on modifie la loi sur la
laïcité de 1905 que on est mal noté par
les anglo saxons depuis qu'on s'attaque
aux sectes par exemple e salle et ça
leur paraître dévieront pourquoi est-ce
qu au nom de quoi s quant à elle
s'attaque aux sectes n'y a que les
français qui s'attaque aux sectes en
pensant qu'on en ferait en réalité
religieuse
voilà donc c'est une secte car on a bien
le droit des attentions
d'abord la loi de 1905 n'est pas une loi
de laïcité c'est une loi de séparation
des églises et de l'état le mot laïcité
n'est même pas prononcé dans la loi de
1905 parce que la ley la laïcité c'est
pas un principe juridique
c'est un principe politique qui se
construit en gros à partir de 1789 c'est
à dire à partir du moment où on décide
de rejeter la monarchie de droit divin
et donc d'inventer une façon de
s'associer qui ne repose pas sur le
divin et petit à petit ça s'approfondit
mais ça ne se résume pas à la loi de
1905 et ça c'est très important parce
que justement il ya toute une offensive
actuellement qui consiste à essayer de
en rond de supprimer cette spécificité
très française pour nous nous aligner
sur le modèle anglo saxon alors la
différence elle est dans la façon dont
on perçoit l'organisation de l'espace
public sert qu'en gros pour simplifier
beaucoup la république
c'est l'idée d'un espace public neutre
dans lequel nous allons tous en tant que
citoyens participé à la délibération et
décider du bien commun et du coup on
vient dans cet espace public en tant que
citoyen c'est-à-dire on laisse un petit
peu nos différences nos identités aux
vestiaires puisque nous sommes là tous
au même titre et nous mettons en avant
ce qui nous rassemble
la démocratie libérale à l'anglo saxonne
c'est une tout autre conception de
l'organisation politique sert c'est
l'idée que les intérêts individuels et
les intérêts des différentes communautés
si l'état garantit simplement à minima
qui n'est que là que la libre
concurrence n'est pas faux c est bien
ses intérêts vont jouer entre eux et
aboutir au bien commun
donc c'est pas du tout la même chose
donc la laïcité à la française c'est
l'idée que l'état est là pour garantir
la neutralité de cet espace public et
pour faire en sorte que le bien commun
ne soit jamais confisqué par un intérêt
privé que ce soit d'ailleurs un intérêt
religieux ou des intérêts financiers
voyez c'est pour ça que pour moi lutter
contre les lobbys par exemple c'est le
même combat que de lutter contre des
religions qui essayent d'influencer la
politique d'obtenir des droits
spécifiques pour des choses comme ça
c'est pareil on attache appelé de toute
façon je vais pas jouer au jeu qui
consiste à vouloir prouver que je suis
plus démocrate que vous donc je vais
admettre que vous avez raison et j'ai
l'impression que mes se battre que j'ai
par exemple l'impression que ce qui
préside aux questionnements qui est le
vôtre sommes-nous encore en démocratie
le la base même l'origine c'est qu'au
fond on mène en france la même politique
depuis trente ans à peu près et on a eu
beau on a changé à chaque fois les têtes
on a changé les étiquettes on est passé
de la gauche à la droite et même ensuite
a ni droite ni gauche à savoir le
maquereau 10 mhz et pourtant c'est
toujours la même politique et ça pour
vous c'est un indice que l'on n'est plus
en démocratie
je me demande si pour autant c'est vrai
c'est à dire qu'au fond à chaque fois
les électeurs ont jugé je pense pas
qu'il se faisait d'illusion si vous
voulez ni en votant pour jacques chirac
ou pour françois hollande pour nicolas
sarkozy ou pourrait baduel backrooms je
pense pas qu'il se faisait d'illusion il
n'avait pas elle ils ont pas voté pour
une grande rupture voyez vous ayez nom
sert que je pense qu'il ya une assez
grande lucidité des électeurs en effet
pour autant le discours sur la fracture
sociale en 95
à une part des électeurs qui a voulu y
croire le discours de nicolas sarkozy
disant on va rétablir une forme de
volonté politique c'est à dire que enfin
ça aura un sens l'action politique
il ya des électeurs qui ont voulu y
croire le discours de françois hollande
consistant à dire nous allons renégocier
le traité budgétaire européen
il ya des gens qui sincèrement ils y ont
cru
donc à chaque fois et emmanuel macron à
jouer sur cette idée de rupture c'est
une escroquerie sans nom mais il a joué
dessus et des électeurs ont voulu croire
que cette fois-ci enfin ça aurait lieu
alors après il ya toujours une part de
même en effet qui se disent nous on sait
très bien qu'on s'est fait avoir à
chaque fois ça va continuer pour autant
ce n'est pas parce que on est lucide que
c'est acceptable mais en fait je dirais
qu'il ya deux moteurs dans la réflexion
j'ai essayé de mener ya celui là en
effet c'est à dire que j'ai voulu
comprendre pourquoi
depuis en effet 30 ou 40 ans la quel que
soit le les orientations du vote quel
que soit les les promesses électorales
c'est en effet la même politique qui est
menée et qui aboutit à quelque chose de
profondément destructeur et puis il ya
un deuxième élément j'allais dire qui
est beaucoup plus viscéral
c'est l'espèce de de révolte de colère
que je peux avoir
quand je constate une forme de mépris
qui s'affiche de façon ouverte contre
certains et cette espèce de deux façons
de considérer qu' il y a des gens qui
n'auraient pas voix au chapitre qui ne
devraient pas avoir le droit de vote qui
ne sont pas aptes à juger et c'est
quelque chose qui me fout hors de moi et
je vis d'abord les deux
et les deux sont en fait totalement lié
et c'est ce que j'essaye d'expliquer
dans le livre mais par exemple au moment
de la révolte des gilets jaunes le
mépris de classe qui a surgi de la part
de certains commentateurs étaient d'une
violence absolument dingue et moi dans
ces cas là je dis regarde en effet une
chose qui me thibault et ris c'est
l'idée que telle personne parce que
c'est une mère célibataire parce que
c'est un petit artisan aurait moins que
moi qui suis agrégée de lettres est
journaliste ou d'autres qui sont là
aurait moins le droit de de donner son
avis de décider de ce que va être le
destin de notre pays et ça c'est un truc
qui me fait bondir hors c'est de plus en
plus violents et on le voit à chaque
élection on l'a vu au moment du
breakbeat c'était fabuleux quand même
d'aller expliquer que ce sont les moins
diplômés qui ont voté le brésil et que
donc il ya certains qui ont su qu'ils
ont émis cette hypothèse ce serait bien
peut-être de réserver le vote à ceux qui
sont plus diplômés alors on est chez les
fous mais au reviendra sur le mépris de
classe mais restons un peu sur le fait
que au fond il ya une idéologie et il ya
un système qui défend cette île de logis
et cela depuis 30 ou 40 ans mais qu'est
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on s'en rend
compte
parce qu'au fond à l'époque où lionel
jospin et premier ministre et que lui
succède
alain juppé les gens font une différence
entre les deux même si la politique de
l'un et de l'autre n'est pas si
différente me font encore une différente
aujourd'hui
ils ne font plus aucune différence entre
manuel valls est un équivalent qu'ils
soient de droite ou ou
où qu'ils soient centriste il ya plus de
différences lacement la caisse qui
est-ce qui a fait qu'à un moment ça
s'est vu pour vous parce que c'est
l'aboutissement d'un processus c'est à
dire que les quelques différences même
de discours disparaissent au fur et à
mesure pourquoi parce que la vérité de
la politique menée la vérité des choses
tend à s'affirmer c'est à dire que en
gros sur le processus se joue sur à peu
près 40 ans dire que aussi il ya dans
les l'histoire des cycles politiques il
y a un cycle qui s'ouvre dans les années
1970 alors on pourrait le daté de 1971
et du moment où les états unis décident
de sortir de bretton-woods c'est-à-dire
décide que le dollar ne sera plus indexé
sur l'or
ça c'est une date économique essentiel
mais en fait ça ne s'affirme qu'à la fin
des années 70 avec margaret thatcher et
ronald reagan c'est à dire c'est ce
qu'on appelle le cycle néolibérale c'est
à dire une politique de dérégulation de
l'ensemble des systèmes économiques
c'est-à-dire de remise en cause en fait
de tous les acquis qui s'était imposé
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale si on
veut là aussi le dire vite tout le xxème
siècle est un moment de conquêtes
sociales avec des soubresauts évidemment
et cette conquête sociale ne peut se
faire que parce que le capitalisme est
mis en danger par le communisme est donc
ça permet d'arracher des conquêtes
sociales à partir du moment où à la fin
des années 1970 on est déjà dans une
phase d'affaiblissement de l'urss et que
sa firme parade parallèlement dans les
pays anglo saxons une école de pensée
qui arrive à imposer ses idées et à
savoir ses idées c'est le fait que
l'état n'est pas la solution mais le
problème est qu'il faut absolument
retirer tous les verrous créer une sorte
de marché mondiale unifiée en supprimant
les normes et les tarifs douaniers en en
uniformisant absolument tout à partir du
moment où tout cela se met à s'imposer
alors vous avez toutes les économies
mondiales qui tombent comme des dominos
et c'est ce qu'on voit au cours des
années 80 puisque en fait sa part donc
des états unis et de la grande bretagne
l'europe devient un poste avancé
notamment grâce à l'acte unique européen
de 1986 qui justement instaure la libre
circulation des capitaux des
marchandises des hommes et met en place
en fait fin détourne le sens de ce
qu'ils étaient l'union européenne avant
cela pour mettre en place ce non plus un
marché commun mais un marché unique et
un marché ouvert sur le monde entier
espèrent que l'europe devient la zone
économiquement la plus ouverte du monde
alors qu'au départ le projet la promesse
européenne c'était quoi s'étaient fondés
sur l'idée de la préférence
communautaire c'est-à-dire en gros
chaque pays va acheter va favoriser les
produits des autres pays européens et
chacun vend ses excédents aux autres et
on s'enrichit mutuellement la à partir
de ce moment là on s'ouvre à tous les
vents et on fait du commerce avec le
reste du monde
de quelle manière mais en allant
chercher à chaque fois les endroits où
la production ne sera la moins chère
c'est à dire qu'on organise le débit à
l'échelle du monde et à l'échelle de
l'union européenne grâce à l'ouverture
aux pays de l'est à l'ancien bloc
communiste après 1989 où là on peut
organiser un dumping social à grande
échelle à l'intérieur même de l'union
européenne et dont et on voit petit à
petit au cours des années 80 90 tous se
mettre en place notamment sous la
pression et c'est ça qui est très
frappant de ce courant on a appelé la
deuxième gauche qui a été ce courant qui
tout en se disant de gauche tout en
l'utilisant des critères de progressisme
pour mettre en avant
son apparence de gauche s'étaient
totalement rallier à cette politique et
les videmment ça se voit notamment dans
les actions de tony blair de bill
clinton bill clinton qui est celui qui a
notamment par exemple aboli le glass
steagall act acte qui interdisait la
fusion entre banques d'affaires et
banques de dépôt c'est à dire que c'est
l'invention de l'économie casino et de
la financiarisation totale du
capitalisme c'est tout ça dont on voit
les conséquences aujourd'hui alors
pourquoi aujourd'hui ça se voit mais
justement parce qu'on arrive au bout du
cycle
c'est à dire que ce les conséquences de
ce système c'est quoi la division
mondiale du travail ça permet d'aller
fabriqués ailleurs moins cher donc sa
ruine les économies des pays occidentaux
on adage bout d'abord vu les pelles et
les classes ouvrières se faire laminer
maintenant ce sont les classes moyennes
et au bout d'un moment ce système ne
peut plus prétendre qu'il favorise
l'ensemble de la population et qu'il
enrichit les gens donc la colère monte
et là il ya une exigence de la part des
citoyens d'une autre politique
et là ils s'aperçoivent que quel que
soit le levier ça ne répond plus à
chaque fois qu'ils demandent une autre
politique
on leur promet pendant les campagnes
électorales et dès qu'on est élu
évidemment on s'empresse de faire le
contraire regardez je citais tout à
l'heure la fracture sociale donc 1995
jacques chirac fait toute sa campagne
sur l'objectif de combler cette fracture
sociale qui est en train de se creuser
c'est à dire donc bien le décrochage des
classes populaires et des petites
classes moyennes 26 octobre 1995 alain
juppé parce que déjà la trahison c'est
quand même que toute cette campagne n'a
été faite par philippe séguin et il
nomme alain juppé premier ministre faire
qu'on sentait déjà que c'était pas
exactement dans la ligne et 26 octobre
alors j'ai fait d'écouter bon on
s'assied sur les promesses de campagne
parce que c'est comme ça on ne va pas
pouvoir et avec toujours ce même
discours qui consiste à dire c'est le
réalisme qui nous oblige mais non c'est
pas le réalisme c'est l'adhésion à ses
principes qui nous enserre dans un
système totalement globale c'est-à-dire
le fait qu'on
de revenir sur la politique de libre
échange généralisé on refuse de mettre
en place une relocalisation de
l'économie qui va permettre de recréer
de l'emploi c'est tout ça qui se passe à
chaque fois mais c'est à chaque fois
mais il ya d'autres sujets où on observe
le même phénomène et qui ne sont pas des
sujets économiques du temps où ils
étaient tous les deux ou au gouvernement
sous françois hollande
vous voyez bien qu'entre emmanuel macron
et manuel valls il y avait une
différence fondamentale dans le rapport
qu'on peut être avoir ou banlieues ou à
l'islam il y avait une vraie différence
est d'ailleurs au moment de sa campagne
électorale
emmanuel macron a montré cette
différence là en permanence une fois au
pouvoir on à gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur d' emmanuel macron qui n'a
rien à envier à manuel valls n'y a ni à
nicolas sarkozy et qui même se flatte
d'être plus dur que marine le pen
donc on voit bien que cette
uniformisation dont vous parlez ne
touche pas seulement l'économie comme on
a l'habitude de le dire mais ça touche
aussi bien d'autres domaines on pourrait
dire de la même manière le rapport aux
états unis à l'atlantisme et cetera
l'uniformisation de des gouvernements
successifs ne porte pas que sur
l'économie c'est vrai à ceci près que là
dans la sueur sur la pratique du pouvoir
des manuels macron essai ces revirements
idéologie idéologique et des choix assez
subtil sterk en fait emmanuel macron
pendant sa campagne de 2017 est une
forme de quintessence du néolibéralisme
à l'anglo-saxonne donc en gros il faut
adapter la france à la mondialisation
l'union européenne telle qu'elle
existait formidable il faut quand même
se souvenir qu'il expliquait que la
directive travailleurs détachés c'était
absolument génial quand une fois qu'il a
été au pouvoir il s'est mis à la
renégocier et en fait c'est vrai sur
tous les domaines
pendant sa campagne de 2017 il était
totalement atlantiste et puis le premier
truc qu'il fait une fois qu'il était
l'une c
très vite et vladimir poutine et de se
positionner comme étant au contraire une
forme de petits veaux et aujourd'hui il
s'inquiète de l'extraterritorialité du
droit américain de l'impérialisme alors
ça ne veut pas dire que dans les faits
ils se donnent les moyens de lutter
contre cela ça reste très ambivalent
mais alors même qu'il était dans cette
lignée finalement qui était celle du
cycle néolibérale le il semblerait que
l'exercice du pouvoir l'obligent à
changer de discours
nous sommes bien d'accord que ce sont
des discours mais en effet lui qui était
aussi sur une conception très très
anglo-saxonne de la communauté nationale
qui évitait à tout prix les questions
justement de laïcité de communautarisme
parce qu'au fond ils ne voyaient pas le
problème s'est mis à adopter un discours
qui aboutit à la loi séparatisme alors
est ce que pour autant c'est une
uniformisation des politiques là je
pense que c'est c'est assez complexe
comme phénomène mais je dirais que là on
va dire le le fait que emmanuel macron
se déporte sur sa droite sur les
questions sécuritaires sur les questions
d'identité de rapport aux religions à
l'islam en particulier vient de du fait
que ces questions là sont les seuls sur
lesquels on peut 2d l'impression d'avoir
une prise elle est totalement factice
puisque de fait les quais ces questions
là ne sont pas réglés ça fait vingt ans
que ça s'enkystent mais ça permet de
tenir un discours qui est un discours en
apparence de volonté politique comme
bien même à côté on a abandonné toute
volonté politique sur les questions
économiques le problème c'est que je
pense qu en fait contrairement à ce que
croient beaucoup d'hommes politiques qui
pratique ce jeu
les deux sont liés c'est à dire que les
la destruction de la communauté
nationale
là
le parc par un phénomène à la fois
d'individualisme et de communautarisme
elle est aussi une conséquence de la
fragmentation des sociétés liées au
néolibéralisme c'est à dire que le
loonie le néolibéralisme à petit à petit
détruits les états-nations c'est même un
des projets du néolibéralisme de
considérer qu'il va falloir s'appuyer
sur des entité supranationale que ce
soit par exemple l'union européenne que
ce soit l'om c'est à dire des éléments
qui vont s'éloigner petit à petit de
l'échelle de l'état nation parce que
c'est à l'échelle de l'état nation que
s'exerce la démocratie
peut-être qu'un jour ce sera différent
mais pour l'instant c'est on n'a rien
inventé d'autres c'est à l'échelle de
l'état justement pas d'autres vous
interrompre donc pas redondante mais est
ce que ce serait pas le meilleur moyen
de le combattre ce néolibéralisme s'ils
tentaient qu'on le considère comme
l'ennemi et c'est votre cas ce serait
justement d'instaurer des gouvernance
mondiale une ou des gouvernance mondiale
se sont elles seules peuvent rétablir de
la démocratie au niveau global où se
situe aujourd'hui le marché
le marché global les démocraties sont
nationale donc par définition elles sont
vaincus d'avancé sauf que je le disais
l'échelle de la démocratie ce sont les
états nations parce que ce sont les
peuples
il ne peut pas y avoir de démocratie
quand il n'ya pas de peuple c'est
d'ailleurs tout le problème que
rencontre l'union européenne
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que dans la
mesure où il n'ya pas de peuple européen
pour l'instant peut-être qu'il y aura un
jour puisque de toute façon faire je le
pense qu'il y a clairement en tout cas
une civilisation européenne et malgré
nos différences il y a une façon commune
de penser la liberté qui n'est pas sûr
qu'on voit ailleurs dans le monde donc
je crois qu'il y à une civilisation mais
il n'ya pas de peuple européen et on l'a
bien vu avec le coronavirus c'est à dire
que deux au pied du mur quand il y à une
crise chaque pays défend les intérêts de
ses citoyens
donc la question c'est de savoir comment
on limite se repli sur soi et comment on
apprend à collaborer mais sans pour
autant imaginer qu'on va tout de suite
fondre les peuples les uns
avec les autres et que tout ça n'aurait
plus de n'aurait plus de vérité dire que
la démocratie nécessite aussi de se
sentir un lien extrêmement profond avec
ceux qui nous entourent
parce que justement nous allons ensemble
avoir un destin commun et le décider
donc c'est pour ça que le l'idée de
gouvernance mondiale ne peut pas marcher
ce serait faire fi des différents
rapports de force des différents
intérêts qui peuvent exister des
cultures qui détermine aussi nos
intérêts notre vision du monde
pour l'instant je suis désolé mais on
n'a pas la même vision de l'être humain
que d'autres pays dans le monde
ce n'est pas vrai donc on va pas pouvoir
s'accorder là dessus il faut ça qu il
faut à l'échelle des nations se mettre
d'accord et ça ne peut se faire que si
les ans n'écrase pas les autres donc on
n'y arrivera pas si on s'affaiblit petit
à petit et si nous perdons notre
indépendance puisque ce qu'on a vu avec
le corona viol c'est ça c'est que
l'europe et la france en particulier
sont en train de perdre leur
indépendance c'est à dire leur capacité
d'action qu'à partir de là le
déséquilibre fait qu'on n'ait et poum
n'est plus libre de décider pour nous
mêmes mais on a tellement rêver d'or de
gouvernance mondiale ça me semble
utopique je vous interromps fait une
pause au ce
on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
fin janvier des petits investisseurs
sont parvenus à se coordonner sur
internet pour faire plier de grands
fonds d'investissement rassurez-vous
vous avez quelques mains qui en ont bien
profité qui ont mis à genoux un album
mais comme comme on faisait déjà depuis
je vous dis 30 ans on la seule
différence est l'effet de foule s'est
organisée sur des réseaux sociaux donc
c'est un peu la version 3.0 des
opérations organisées entre
investisseurs ne faut pas considérer ça
comme la révolution des petits contre
les gros et c'est non cdti beaucoup plus
malins qui sont des grosses mains et qui
ont organisé leur coup on nous vend un
peu le conte de fées que c'est que des
sardines qui ont attaqué le requin est
en fait je pense que parmi les sardines
y avait aussi des rockers
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe tron était le
seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qui unira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
sommes nous toujours
sommes nous encore en démocratie c'est
le titre du livre que natacha polony
vient de publier aux éditions de
l'observatoire
on continue d'en parler jours et qu'on
revienne sur ce mépris de classe dont
vous parlez beaucoup dans ce livre lors
vous en parlait beaucoup dans le sens où
ils vous choque particulièrement c'est
le mépris des classes dominantes pour
les classes populaires
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
qu'il ya aussi un mépris des classes
populaires envers les classes dominantes
qu'elle voit forcément comme des vendus
systématiquement des gens qui n'ont qui
n'ont pas de qui n'ont pas d'honneur qui
n'ont pas de qui n'ont pas de fierté
comme des sacs capable aussi des gens
qui n'arrivent à rien qui en dépit de
leur diplôme en dépit de leur morgue et
de leur arrogance sont complètement nul
c'est à dire que ils sont d'après ce que
vous dites et d'après ce que pense très
souvent les classes populaires
ils sont une classe sociale notre élite
c'est une classe sociale
nos représentants sont tous issus de
cette classe sociale il en défendent les
intérêts et pourtant comme vous l'avez
dit la france dégringole
c'est à dire que les élites françaises
aujourd'hui sont de - font de moins en
moins partie des élites européennes par
exemple on décroche comme dans le
tableau 2e que de beast là et quand on
fait ce portrait là des élites
françaises en fin du mois des classes
dominantes
est-ce que c'est pas du mépris de classe
alors je ne parlerai pas de mépris je
parlerai éventuellement de colère
parfois de détestation excessives
parfois même de haine de la part de
certains oui c'est vrai et il cette
fracture elle est de plus en plus
importante
alors après
la question de savoir comment est née
cette fracture est essentiel mais il me
semble en tout cas qu'il ya un point qui
est fondamental c'est que la promesse
républicaine c'est celle justement d'un
renouvellement des élites c'est pour ça
que l'école est au coeur de la
république est la question la
méritocratie en particulier pourquoi
parce qu'un pays qui ne renouvelle pas
25% de ses élites à peu près à chaque
génération est un pays qui crève
or là pourquoi yat-il cette fracture est
donc cette détestation de la part de
certains vis-à-vis des élites qui sont
perçus comme étant en effet responsable
de l'état de la france de la
dégringolade responsable de la
destruction de tous deux de l'appareil
est par exemple des services publics
d'abord c'est vrai en effet qu'il y a eu
des choix qu'ils étaient des choix
délétère et qui viennent d'une d'une
forme d'entre eux soit de ses élites et
du fait que comme elle ne se
renouvellent pas les idées ne se
renouvelle pas il n'y a pas de
concurrence de remise en cause de
discussions de débats on est dans une
homogénéité absolue
donc je pense que le problème n'est pas
de savoir si
les
si ceux qui crachent sur les élites ont
tort ou raison le problème est de poser
le bon diagnostic
nous sommes dans un pays et c'est vrai
dans tous les pays occidentaux en voie
de fracturation total l'historien
christopher lasch avait diagnostiqué en
1994 ce qu'il appelait la sécession des
élites dire qu'il expliquait que la
mondialisation avait créé une classe
sociale mondiale des élites qui en fait
n'avait plus les mêmes intérêts que les
citoyens du pays auquel elle était
censée appartenir mais qu'elle avait
plus de proximité avec les autres élites
des autres pays
et ça c'est aussi ce que provoque cette
dérégulation des flux de capitaux de
marchandises qui permet aux uns et aux
autres de passer d'un pays à l'autre de
faire passer leurs capitaux d'un pays à
l'autre et de ne plus être ancrée
territorialement la conséquence elle est
celle que nous voyons c'est à dire en
effet une détestation parfois totalement
excessives de la part de certaines de
certains citoyens pour les élites
oui il ya une forme de violence et on
l'a vu notamment là aussi au mouvement
des gilet jaune
on a vu une haine se manifester qui
était extrêmement dangereuse mais elle
vient ou petit à petit ce décrochage est
elle vient du fait qu' il n'y a aucun
brassage et qu'à aucun moment les
citoyens ne peuvent se dire car qu'ils
feront partie des élites ou conner
enfants feront partie de ses élites et
je pense que la question de la
destruction de l'ascenseur social qui
est particulièrement forte en france est
aussi un des éléments à prendre en
compte mais du coup ce qui ce qui
découle de tout ça c'est aussi la
destruction de la démocratie
représentative
parce qu'en effet vous l'avais dit à
l'instant et c'est ce que j'essaye
d'expliquer dans le livre c'est que ces
élites sont celles qui ont tous les
postes de représentants et donc à partir
du moment où vous avez des représentants
qui en fait se reproduisent entre eux et
ne représente qu'une seule classe
sociale la démocratie représentative ne
peut plus fonctionner c'est pour ça que
là aussi au moment dé gilet jaune
quand il ya eu ce débat démocratie
participative contre eux ou directes
contre démocratie représentative dire
tout ce qu'ils disaient mais c'est un
scandale il n'y a de vraies démocraties
que représentative à d'accord mais si
elle marche pas on fait quoi
or quand vous avez dans de plus en plus
souvent l'une un vote des représentants
qui est totalement déconnectée des
aspirations des citoyens
ça ne peut pas fonctionner quand vous
avez 55 % des français qui votent contre
le traité constitutionnel européen et
90% des députés qui vont voter le même
texte
trois ans plus tard ça prouve qu'il y à
un décrochage total et donc on n'est
plus tout à fait en démocratie la
démocratie ne fonctionne plus et c'est
même la communauté nationale en tant que
communauté politique qui est en train
d'éclater
qui est qui est exclue du débat est-ce
que ce que vous décrivez en fait c'est
un système clos où finalement tout le
monde serait victime de sa propre
propagande mais qui est exclue du débat
il ya les populistes les complotistes
alors les termes populiste et
complotistes ce sont des termes
largement instrumentalisée parce que
populiste c'est un terme qui a une
définition précise c'est un courant
politique on peut le décrire au 19e
siècle né en russie
voilà et ensuite c'est une méthode c'est
à dire ceux ci on veut le définir
véritablement ça consiste on l'idée d'un
leader qui incarne la volonté directe du
peuple sans passer par justement les
formes de la représentation des corps
intermédiaires et qui serait l'émanation
de cette volonté du peuple et d'un
peuple qui est vu comme uniforme unifiée
or
je pense que justement l'idée qu'il
pourrait y a existé un peuple totalement
unifiée me semble assez dangereuse je
pense que ce qui est intéressant dans la
démocratie c'est justement le fait
qu'elle assume la diversité que c'est un
rapport permanent entre l'un et le
diverses mais le populisme ça existe en
revanche le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que le terme populiste est accolée à
tout ce qui déplaît en gros tout ce qui
remet en cause le système
et là aussi je le montre dans le livre
il ya une continuité dans le la
diabolisation à travers divers
changement de vocabulaire donc il ya eu
une période où c'était le terme
réactionnaires qui désignait ce qui
mettait en danger le système est donc il
fallait diaboliser le terme
réactionnaire surgi en 2002 après juste
après l'arrivée au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle de
de jean marie le pen est donc en
septembre 2002 par est un livre qui
s'intitule le rappel à l'ordre
enquête sur les nouveaux réactionnaires
et qui consiste en une listes
d'intellectuels qui sont coupables
d'avoir critiqué la démocratie telle
qu'elle existe en disant qu'elle n'était
pas satisfaisante et donc on leur met
sur le dos l'arrivée au second tour de
jean marie le pen en expliquant qu' ils
ont favorisé ça puisqu'ils ont critiqué
le système donc les bons et
réactionnaire qui était effectivement
ont dénoncé avec beaucoup de 2-2-2
d'énergie à cette époque là aujourd'hui
il anime des émissions de télévision les
mêmes réactionnaire c'est exquis été
dénoncés il ya encore pas très longtemps
il ya moins de 20 ans est devenu un must
aujourd'hui ça fait de l'audience ça
plaît beaucoup
tous les médias de valeurs
réactionnaires donc on voit bien que ça
change
oui alors d'abord dans la set list de
réactionnaire il y avait des gens on ne
peut plus beau des récom marcel gauchet
pierre manent on peut pas dire que ce
soit non plus des troubles des trublions
ses dires le le délire absolu que
consistait enfin en quoi consistait ce
livre et c'est bien le problème ça
démontre que le terme réactionnaire a
été accolé à des gens pour expliquer
qu'ils étaient dans le camp du mal et
aujourd'hui c'est le terme populiste et
c'est même le terme complotistes alors
après c'est vrai que les choses ont
bougé
c'est à dire que dans les années phares
des années 90 début des années 2000 il y
avait une forme de chape de plomb dans
les médias ou en fait seule la pensée
conforme au système était acceptée et il
était extrêmement difficile de faire
entendre une voix différente c'est
d'ailleurs ça la clé du succès d'eric
zemmour c'est juste qu'il était le seul
et que du coup il a cristallisé cette
attente de la part des certes de
certains d'entendre un autre discours
et avec tous ses excès toutes ces îles à
il sut il a renforcé enfin il était
renforcé par le fait qu' il paraissait
le seul à avoir le courage de dénoncer
le système mais c'est vrai que les
choses ont bougé parce que maintenant en
effet d
gens qui sont en opposition il y en a
énormément pourquoi parce que du coup le
système médiatique s'est recomposé pour
construire des oppositions frontales
mais ça ne veut pas dire que le débat
politique est plus un ça veut dire qu'il
y à des oppositions mise en scène
exactement comme on assure le dans le
paysage politique une mise en scène
entre delà du combat entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen
mais pour autant on voit bien que
l'option marine le pen est interdite
c'est à dire que on a avant on avait une
alternance factice entre droite de
gouvernement et gauche de gouvernement
ça fonctionnait on passer de l'un à
l'autre c'était toujours la même
politique
le système s'est recomposé parce que ça
ne fonctionnait plus de cette façon là à
travers la jonction des libéraux de
droite et les libéraux de gauche et face
à ce qu'on peut appeler ben voilà ce
qu'on appelle le populisme sauf que le
populisme n'est pas une option
donc il n'y a même plus d'alternative
d'alternance factice il n'ya plus que la
possibilité d'un vote unique
ben ce n'est pas la démocratie la
démocratie c'est justement de pouvoir
oui vous ne croyez pas que aujourd'hui
pour y avoir très bien comme l'a montré
gérald darmanin mais d'autres l'avaient
fait avant lui y compris à gauche
en devenant à leur tour sécuritaire anti
islam anti banlieue etc etc
au fond qui pourrait y avoir d'aidé
alors on écarte l'original jean-marie le
pen ou même marine le pen et puis on
prend une décalcomanie mais quelqu'un
qui au fond appliquerait le même
programme mais sans en avoir les
caractéristiques un peu soi disant
repoussante
oui mais qui appliqueraient quel
programme
le programme en effet sécuritaires et
identitaires mais dans quel but
dans le but de préserver en revanche
locker les tubes problème à savoir le
programme économique
on est bien dans la construction
politique pour empêcher la remise en
cause d'un système qui est fondée sur le
libre échange la division mondiale et
après tu sûr dans les bacs sur le peuple
comme vous dites vous êtes sûr que sur
ces questions là une majorité pourrait
se dessiner dans un pays comme la france
c'est à dire pour refuser pour qu'il y
ait moins d'europe qu'il y ait moins de
monnaie unique qu'il y ait moins d'union
européenne qu'il y ait moins de
frontières est-ce que vous devrez
véritablement vous êtes si mal c'est pas
moins d'europe c'est pas moins d'europe
c'est pas moins de monnaie unique c'est
je pense un consensus vers une europe
qui défendent véritablement les citoyens
c'est à dire une europe qui soit une
puissance et pour cela ça nécessite que
la france mette en place un rapport de
force et que donc les gouvernants
français tout simplement considèrent que
leur rôle est de défendre les intérêts
des citoyens qui les ont élus
or là je pense qu'ils pourraient se
dessiner un consensus parce que quand on
regarde les dynamique électorale de ces
dernières années le cher le la demande
justement 95 de lutte contre la fracture
sociale
c'est une demande de remise en cause de
ce système
quand on voit le moment où chevénement
monde
évidemment après il s'effondre mais où
il s'effondre pour des raisons qu'on
peut expliquer mais cette demande
à un moment donné il incarne une
dynamique parce qu'il est dans ce
discours de remise en cause de ce
système et on voit comment petit à petit
ça se construit dans à peu près toutes
les élections on peut aussi regarder par
exemple les la liste des premières
revendications des gilets jaunes
celle qui avait été publié dans le jdd
alors certes on peut ergoter est-ce que
c'était représentatif pas représentatif
y avait 42 propositions
elle était très intéressante tous les
médias ont dit oui mais c'est
contradictoire ça part dans tous les
sens pas du tout quand on regarde
c'était extrêmement précis ce n'était
que des propositions qui permettait
j'allais dire pour reprendre
l'expression britannique né après le
break site de reprendre le contrôle et
de recréer une forme d'égalité puisque
ça consistait d'abord sur le plan fiscal
à dire que les gros payent beaucoup et
les petits un peu moins c'est à dire un
système qui ne favorise pas les
multinationales face aux pme c'était
l'idée qu'il fallait faire en sorte de
favoriser l'emploi local et pour ça de
pratiquer une forme de protectionnisme
c'était l'idée qu'on allait là aussi sur
le plan de l'immigration accueillir ce
qu'on avait décidé d'accueillir les
accueillir bien d'ailleurs il y avait
une vraiment un renforcement du droit
d'asile mais à côté de ça reconduire à
la frontière ce dont on avait décidé
qu'il n'avait pas vocation à rester faye
avait cette idée tout simplement de la
souveraineté
en fait c'était le coeur du discours la
souveraineté c'est-à-dire la capacité
pour les citoyens de décider de leur
destin
or je pense que si on débat réellement
c'est à dire si positionne les choses de
cette façon
en dix ans nous d'accord pour justement
avoir les leviers
si nous sommes nous d'accord pour
décider que par exemple nous devons ré
industrialiser parce que c'est la seule
façon de ne pas retrouver à la prochaine
crise de nouveau à quémander des masques
des thèses tout ce genre de choses
voyez il ya des tas de choses comme ça
qui peuvent justement obtenir un
consensus et je pense que moi ce que
j'essaie d'expliquer dans mon livre
c'est finalement que l'escroquerie à
consiste à présenter le paysage
politique comme une espèce de continuité
où il y aurait donc le centre qui serait
donc l'alliance des libéraux de droite
et des libéraux de gauche
et puis après il ya des extrêmes mais
les français en effet sont des gens
raisonnables ils ne veulent pas des
extrêmes ils ne veulent pas d'un de
l'extrême gauche ne veulent pas non plus
de l'extrême droite dans sa dimension de
rejet de l'autre
globalement je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
une adhésion majoritaire au
rassemblement national en revanche si on
présente les choses comme ça c'est sûr
que la situation est bloquée il y aura
toujours ce centre qui est qui adhèrent
aux idées néo libérales et qui défend ce
système
c'est donc le principe le la seule façon
de sortir de là c'est de construire une
opposition à ce système mais qui se
situe là aussi de façon centrale c'est à
dire qui ne soit pas dans les extrêmes
mais qui est une proposition politique
qui soit une proposition de remise en
cause radicale de tout ce qui est en
train de détruire le non seulement la
république mais la france les deux à la
fois
mais la tâche à peu le dit dans votre
livre vous êtes effectivement très
concentré à la fois sur l'économie et
sur la politique on pourrait dire qu'il
ya plein d'autres domaines dans lesquels
la france est peu traître de moins en
moins une démocratie ou en tout cas
devient une démocratie défaillante et je
suis étonné que vous nous fassiez jamais
allusion par exemple la guerre contre le
terrorisme a réduit nos libertés
considérablement et pas forcément de
façon très efficace
la guerre contre la drogue par exemple
le fait que la france est le premier
pays consommateur de cannabis en europe
et on continue de faire semblant de
mener la guerre contre les
narcotrafiquants ça mobilise des
policiers sa dépense de l'argent
en fait c'est du laxisme pourquoi ne pas
le dire et à chaque fois ça réduit nos
libertés après tout on est assez
grandirait beaucoup de français pour
savoir si on doit fumer du cannabis ou
pas
ebp l'annoncé détaille dit que c'est
chez vous dire oui je ne pouvais pas
j'ai volontairement c'est un petit livre
pour qu'ils soient pédagogiques rapide
et c'est donc je ne pouvais pas aborder
toutes ces questions mais cela dit ça
fait déjà quelques temps que je
j'explique dans diverses prises de
position dans divers éditoriaux ou des
choses comme ça à quel point je pense
j'ai fini par penser que la légalisation
pas la dépénalisation âme et la
légalisation du cannabis était peut-être
la seule solution pour en finir avec les
trafics et pour essayer de régler la
question des banlieues des quartiers
difficiles et je pense que alors après
le la question que ça m'empêche pas de
penser que le cannabis est extrêmement
dangereux et qu' il faut une véritable
prévention c'est à dire justement une
politique de santé
or justement le fait que ce soit
interdit empêche toute politique de son
solide dans ces questions là c'est
totalement absurde
donc je en revanche ce que j'essaye
d'expliquer dans ce livre c'est le fait
que une véritable démocratie doit
s'appuyer sur l'intelligence humaine et
moi c'est mon moteur il est là c'est que
finalement je suis une vraie
progressistes dans le sens où je crois
profondément à une amélioration possible
à un progrès de l'être humain par la
diffusion des savoirs par justement le
fait que si chacun est traité comme un
citoyen il se comportera comme un
citoyen et si nous mettons en place une
société dont l'objet soit de permettre à
chacun de trouver sa forme de bonheur
c'est à dire non pas d'imposer un
bonheur collectif mais de penser la
possibilité d'un bonheur collectif
et bien si on met en place tout cela
nous irons vers une société qui soit
davantage vivable donc je pense que ça
ne peut se fonder que sur la confiance
en la liberté humaine la liberté fondée
sur la raison c'est pour ça que c'est un
mot qui revient tout au long de mon
livre la rationalité la démocratie
présume le fait que nous partageons une
rationalité universelle qui nous permet
de nous comporter comme des citoyens
c'est à dire comme des adultes autonomes
et responsables
or on voit très bien dans tous les
exemples que vous avez cités à quel
point ce n'est absolument pas le cas
et la crise du coronavirus n'a fait que
montrer que les gouvernants prenait les
citoyens pour des enfants à qui il
fallait interdire des choses et imposer
d'autres choses c'est à dire que à aucun
moment on ne favorise lusage de
l'intelligence et ça je pense que c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce qu'on a des
outils techniques aujourd'hui qui
diminue encore l' usage de
l'intelligence et on peut dire la même
chose d'ailleurs de ce projet de loi
contre les ai laissé le séparatif qui
est devenu un projet de loi confortant
les principes républicains où on a vu
tous nos ministres parler des valeurs
républicaines qu'il fallait enseigné à
l'école comme si l'école était fait pour
qu'on enseigne des valeurs là aussi j'ai
l'impression c'est une réduction de
liberté une réduction de la démocratie
que de vouloir enseigner à nos enfants
le bien et le mal à l'école qu'on nous
enseigne la loi oui ce qui est juste et
ce qui est injuste mais le bien et le
mal c'est réservé à chacun sa n'est pas
à l'état de nous l'affligé alors je
crois que la république est un système
qui est fondée sur l'adhésion à des
valeurs en revanche l'école républicaine
n'est pas là pour nous enseigner le bien
et le mal et pour pratiquer un
catéchisme républicain ce qu'elle fait
pourtant depuis des années l'école le
projet de l'école républicaine c'est en
effet de développer la liberté humaine
par la confrontation avec les savoirs
universelle versée par ce que nous
acquérons c'est savoir que nous pourrons
penser par nous-mêmes que nous allons
construire notre raison notre logique et
que donc nous dépendrons plus d'autrui
pour notre jugement c'est simple
principe de l'école républicaine c'est
pas de nous dire le racisme c'est mal le
tri sélectif c'est bien c'est c'est
absolument pas ça donc là on a
totalement détruit cela une fois de plus
parce que on perd de vue ce que c'est
que la liberté et la liberté c'est pas
juste le droit de faire ce qu'on veut la
liberté c'est un processus c'est-à-dire
le fait petit à petit de permettre à
chacun de s'émanciper de tous les
déterminismes qui pesait sur lui de
permettre à chacun d'être maître de son
destin et de
décider librement s'il va adhérer à tel
ou tel système s'il va choisir telle ou
telle option dans sa vie et ensuite de
participer à la chose publique c'est à
dire une délibération collective
vous avez souvent prononcé l'expression
destin commun et pour vous c'est très
important voit bien dans le livre une
démocratie c'est un peuple qui donc se
choisit un destin commun et pourtant on
peut se demander qu at-on encore en
commun c'est à dire aujourd'hui les
français traversé par des siècles de
migration des changes et aujourd'hui ça
s'est encore renforcée à part depuis la
crise sanitaire on est terriblement
replier sur nous-mêmes et où les avions
ne décollent plus qu'au compte gouttes
mais sinon on est traversé de toutes les
influences imaginables à notre époque on
peut regarder des chaînes de télévision
du monde entier et c'est alors qu'est ce
qui nous reste en commun à part je
dirais la langue les paysages et les
services publics
mais sinon cateau en commun s c'est déjà
beaucoup les paysages moi j'avais écrit
un livre en c'était en octobre 2015 qui
s'appelait nous sommes la france
je l'avais écrit en fait après les
attentats de charlie hebdo et d'hyper
cacher pour essayer de réfléchir à ce
que nous avions en commun justement
c'est à dire la question de savoir ce
qu'ils avaient été attaqués par le
terrorisme et qu'est ce que nous avions
encore à défendre et à partager ensemble
et il y avait toute une partie du livre
qui essayez de réfléchir en fait à ce
qui n'est pas négociable sert quand je
disais tout à l'heure il ya un rapport
permanent entre l'un et le diverses
eh bien il ya des choses qui font partie
de ce que nous sommes collectivement et
qui ne sont pas négociables me
semble-t-il est
on pourrait les définir c'est une
certaine idée de la liberté humaine de
la dignité humaine une certaine idée de
l'égalité et notamment la mixité dans
l'espace public c'est très
spécifiquement française je parle de la
mixité entre les hommes et les femmes
c'est à dire que la france c'est une
civilisation qui ne ressemble ni à cette
forme de séparatisme méditerranéen vous
les femmes vivent d'un côté les hommes
de l'autre ni à l'autre forme de
séparatisme entre hommes et femmes qu'on
trouve dans les sociétés anglo saxon il
ya quelque chose de très intéressant à
travers la galanterie l'amour courtois
avant ça bon ça fait partie des
spécificités qui prendra pourtant elle
est en train de disparaître cette
spécificité vous le sentez bien cuit
tout ça est en train de disparaître avec
need to avec un toutes sortes de règles
que l'on est en train de s'instaurer
d'instaurer certainement à bonne escient
ça n'est pas la question mais on est en
train de tout ça est en train de
disparaître
il nous reste 30 secondes je vous laisse
le mot de la fin seconde en 30 secondes
il ya eu un rouleau compresseur du soft
power américain qui ne me semble pas un
progrès parce que même si là encore une
fois nous sommes dans une société qui
n'est pas parfaite mais il y a dans le
projet porté par l'humanisme et les
lumières quelque chose de profondément
intéressant de profondément moderne et
que nous devrions justement à les
creuser pour l'amplifier encore et je
crois je crois que ce serait une très
très belle idée de l'être humain que
nous pourrions développer
sommes nous encore en démocratie c'est
le titre du livre ii des tâches applaudi
qui viennent de paraître aux éditions de
l'observatoire merci d'avoir passé toute
cette heure avec nous natacha polony
merci de nous avoir si vomir et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
oui